[Music]
the feels are gonna come up with
Riverdale and now you're part of young
Hollywood you're here at this event does
it feels surreal is it exciting I mean
all of the above obviously and so much
more and then also exactly where I'm
supposed to be so it's like this really
weird mix of emotions where I'm like
excited and I'm nervous and then I'm
like feel at home I don't know how to
explain it but I'm really happy to be
here you know you can't say much but
what can you tell me about Cheryl's
journey as we going to season 2 she does
get colder meaner believe it or not no
it's not possible
you're not right exactly I thought I
thought too and she gets an unexpected
love interest someone that's already on
the show someone knew it I believe it's
someone new and if somebody that you
wouldn't expect it's what you would it's
not the typical thing you would expect
for a young girl that's all I'm gonna
say okay so maybe somebody different
tastes that you would expect Michele
it's just different and that's all I'm
gonna say we talked about your first
splurge after you got that first
Riverdale
I wish I was hearing I actually usually
always wear I bought myself a rose gold
Cartier ring to celebrate season two
that's so special yeah and I think now
every season I'm gonna buy myself like
one nice piece of jewelry so I can
always wear with me to remind me of
where I came from and how lucky I am to
be here yeah I love that and then I saw
you with a young man over you yeah
Travis my boyfriend
have you guys been dating about five
months or so it's newish yeah here
Riverdale fan he is the Riverdale fan
yeah yeah I need two words to describe
season two unexpected life-changing
[Music]